- I've had one panic attack in my life,
- Okay.
- And I read this on you
like, that you suffer
from panic attacks and anxiety, right?
Yes.
- I had one when I was
pregnant with my little girl
- You were pregnant!
- And I was driving and I couldn't move.
Like, I was like, oh my
God, am I about to die?
And I was literally
looking at my hands and
That's what it feels like.
I was like, and I couldn't breathe,
like it was shallow breathing,
- Yes!
I'd never experienced that
and it was my first
pregnancy that that happened
with my little girl.
And I read that you suffer from anxiety
and panic attacks, too.
I do, I do.
- And, how do you deal with that?
I have had them my whole life,
it's so interesting for me and
this is obviously, probably
with you too but I don't get
them when I'm performing.
Like, I feel most at home
Yeah.
when I'm on stage,
like I don't have any anxiety about that
but I get them just in my day-to-day life
and you know my life changed overnight
with, Two Broke Girls.
I you know, went from being a nanny, ahh,
and a bartender full-time
and then was on national
television, a lot of pressure,
as you know.
Yeah.
American Idol!
Cocktail waitress.
It happened to you too!
I was a cocktail waitress!
Yeah.
To national TV.
We have so much in common Beth
We are so...
I can't wait to ride horses in the woods
and have like,
the other,
I'll be on a four-wheeler
and you stay on your horse.
Okay!
(laughing)
That sounds good!
Yeah, your horse, your mare
We'll keep her away from us,
I'm like my butt hurts!
Beth, ahh.
I don't want
(laughing)
her to learn bad behavior.
Anyways so, I started to notice
that my anxiety got worse.
Not while I was performing,
just off-camera red carpets.
I don't do well,
Yeah.
with anything like that.
And so,
Red carpets are horrible!
They're the worst!
Yeah.
People don't know but it's,
Your smile,
Yes!
- all of a sudden I start
looking like I have a disease.
And it goes like this
Cuz it starts twitching.
Yes!
And I'm like, then I have
to make myself laugh,
so I'm like,
ha ha ha ha ha
- Oh my God.
(laughing)
I try to get it to like not.
They're like, Kelly, Kelly!
You're like,
Yeah.
am I hearing voices, or
is someone talking to me?
I don't know what's happening?
- And they're yelling at you.
Yeah.
It's not polite.
It's like, KELLY!
And I'm like you know.
And then they get you
Yeah.
in the one angle
And then they get
you looking terrible
you looking really hot.
Yeah.
It's
I can see how that would cause
a panic attack.
But all of it, you know.
And actually, Whitney
Cummings who's co-creator
of Two Broke Girls and I said to her,
you know when, my character on the show
had a horse living in New
York City, named Chestnut.
And when the horse was on
the show I noticed that
I was calmer, more grounded at rehearsal,
I was so happy I mean
I always loved animals.
Yeah.
But there was something about the horse,
and I mentioned it to Whitney,
and Whitney was like, I have a friend,
her name is Cassandra Ogier,
she's this incredible equine therapist.
Oh yeah.
You don't have to ride, you
don't have to do anything
it's all on the ground,
it's super spiritual.
Go, work with her.
And she completely changed my life.
Wow!
'Cause horses are prey animals,
so they only live in the present moment.
You know they can smell if
a mountain lion is far away.
So, in order to work with them,
which you know, but if
you're not a horse person
people don't understand this,
but they will only respond
to your authentic behavior
in that moment.
So, if you're scared but
you're trying to show that
you're not scared, they're gonna' be like,
boy, bye.
Like because,
They sense it.
Yeah.
And so, something I
found really empowering,
which is why I believe in equine therapy,
is that when you realize this huge animal,
that could kill you, responds when
you're just your pure authentic self.
Whether you're happy, sad, angry,
whatever it is that day,
you get to show up as
you are and that's enough
and their gonna' want to
respond and communicate
because,
Wow.
They're feeling your authentic truth
and I thought that, that was
one of the most empowering things
and it really helped me
get over my panic attacks.
That's really cool!